they're preparing for a new Cricket
season here and a new culture
so hate doesn't go unchallenged again
and no one suffers racism like azimrafiq
and is denied Justice for so long
case is only now proven years later
against five former Yorkshire teammates
one of the main reasons I spoke out was
to talk about institutional racism uh
and the wider game and at Yorkshire uh
and that's been upheld so
um you know yeah I feel very Vindicated
but five years after first telling
Yorkshire and recently reliving his
trauma at a cricket disciplinary
commission how do you feel the hearings
going how are you feeling all right
hearings Matthew Hoggard Tim bresnan
Andrew Gale Richard pyra and John Blaine
would not participate in
the five who played alongside Rafiq now
found by the panel to have made racist
slurs about him or his sister
I knew Michael Vaughn attended to
contest charges and the case was not
proven against the former captain of
England and Yorkshire
it's centered on this pre-match huddle
in 2009 and the accusation he said there
are too many of you lot at Rafiq and
three other Yorkshire teammates of Asian
descent the panel concluded there were
inconsistences in the evidence from
Rafiq and Adil Rashid
born welcome the verdict in a statement
speaking of the toll of the case on him
and supportive of a healing process
across cricket
he doesn't want the dismissal of his
charge to detract from the fact that
there is an issue issues have been
highlighted throughout the whole process
that do need to be addressed
Rafiq himself has apologized in the past
for posting anti-semitic comments and
qriket as a whole is working now to be
more inclusive look I'm not going to
sugarcoat that things aren't bad you
know we are where we are but I am I am
Keen to see that we make progress and
and that requires
um some very robust EDI strategies and
plans and outcomes you know which are
tangible and and can be actually set up
and said that you know this is what
we're changing and this is the outcomes
this is one of the biggest scandals in
English cricket history involving its
most successful County Yorkshire have
admitted to failing to address the
systemic use of racist language over
many years here now they're waiting to
discover their punishment from the ECB
along with the five who've had their
cases against them proven
at headingley there's still a tarnish
reputation to fix but finally there's a
sense of closure for azzie Murphy after
a career loss to racism racism that
seemed to be ignored for too long by too
many leaving deep wounds still to heal
across Cricket Rob Harris Sky News Leeds